hey what's up everybody this is Titan
from titans of CNC and today I'm excited
because we're gonna take the level of
teaching up a notch alright so today
we're gonna actually focus on aerospace
and machining a very hard material so
the material that I'm talking about is
inconel 625 so you may be asking why do
I have to tighten 1m right here
guess what it's a little different it's
bigger now so now instead of being three
quarters of an inch
it's actually one and a quarter by three
by six so it's a big part and we're not
machining it out of aluminum
we're machining it out of inconel 625
which is a standard material that we use
in the aerospace industry this is one of
the reasons why titans of cnc academy
has now come out with bibi aero building
blocks Aero which consists of actual
aerospace components because we want you
guys to actually learn on real parts
that matter but running inconel is not
as easy right it doesn't cut like butter
it is horde material so you have to
upgrade your tools now when you step up
to titanium and inconel and Monell and
15-5 and harder materials you need a
different tool
you need a different approach but then
when we step up and cut a material with
a high nickel content the cooling the
lubricity all of it comes into play and
the cooling can literally make you or
break you all right so the first thing
that we're gonna do is actually cut the
top surface of our part and to do that
we're gonna use a three-inch dodeca mini
shell mil so the answer that we're using
is not the answer that I used ten years
ago this is a new insert is the kcs
m40 it's a special blend of carbide so
you can machine a perfect part
consistently so we're using this shale
mill to create the first datum the first
perfect surface and then when we drop
down and create pockets and holes all
the dimensions will come off that
surface so you see the part right here I
got my excess inconel the material I'm
holding on to on the outside and then I
got material all the way around and I
got material on the top okay so if we
actually go into my set up and go into
edit come to stock you can see exactly
how much material I've left so we have a
hundred eighty five thousandths on X
negative x positive 115 thousandths in Y
so 115 in the back 115 up front I have
20,000 right here on the top surface and
I have three hundred forty thousands on
the bottom surface alright so let me
explain the speeds and fees for the
dodeca mini we have a service foot of
200 which has given us an RPM of 254 and
we have five inserts on this shell Mel
so when you look at our actual beeper to
zero zero five six is way on the bottom
because the range on this specific tool
and insert is point zero zero five six
two point zero two two eight so as you
can see we got sky on the other side but
since this is a tutorial I wanted to
slow things down alright so in this pass
we're just taking a little bit of
material on the top but it is Inc you
know and we want to have a beautiful
surface finish so another thing that
I've done is we've taken one insert out
brought in a wiper so what is a wiper so
it's an insert that we use to bring out
a beautiful surface finish so all the
other answers actually come down
have a radius at the bottom that
actually is cutting the material the
wiper actually has a flat on the bottom
the flat is about a hundred and ninety
thousand s wide and the wiper actually
sits lower than all the other inserts so
if the inserts were at zero the wiper
would be set down at negative point zero
zero two eight all right so that's the
difference between the two and what
happens is the first four inserts are
gonna come and cut the metal and then
the wipers gonna come back and clean all
right so we're starting out with two and
a surface foot but on the machine I
might raise it a little bit to get a
little bit more rpms and then I will
adjust my chip load to slow or speed it
up to get that perfect finish this shell
metal comes across and just skims
perfectly across that surface all right
so the first tool is complete now let's
go to the next tool the next thing I'm
gonna do is actually come down and
actually rough out this pocket rough out
all the material and start bringing the
part to shape I know that bringing an
end mill into this inconel straight down
is a problem right we can helical and
put a lot of wear on the bottom of that
tool and possibly get it done but that
also is gonna take a long time so to
solve that problem I'm going to take one
of my multi-purpose drills that I use
all the time the go drill this is a
solid carbide coolant through drill that
can pretty much drill anything so from
steels to stainless to titanium to
inconel monel this drill they can get
the job done if I was going into
production and I was running thousands
of parts I probably go to an insert
drill right like the Ken tip or the Ken
tip FS or something similar so once the
tool got dull all I would have to do at
that point is change out the ends
which is a lot less carbide to pay for
it makes it affordable in this case the
go drill is the perfect choice so the
reason that I'm actually using a drill
is to pre-drill where the N mo is going
to drop down into the pocket so my n
mill is gonna be a half an inch I just
need a bigger drill diameter than the
end mill so for the go drill I'm gonna
use three quarters of an inch that gives
me an eighth of an inch all the way
around for clearance this is extremely
important because when the drill drills
its gonna leave a tapered bottom because
the drill point is not flat it's at an
included angle at a hundred and forty
degrees so when the end mill drops down
it's actually going to hit the tapered
material before it hits the bottom so
because I have a bigger drill than the
end mill when I'm about a hundred
thousand shy of hitting the bottom I'm
simply going to step over and like a
hundred and ten thousand and I'm just
gonna heal it cool down to full depth at
that point once they get to full depth
I'm gonna start peripheral milling and
just hogging out all that inconel
alright so now they were ready to drill
let's look at the speed of the drill so
the recommended surface foot that I'm
gonna give you is about 70 to 130 for
the tutorial I'm gonna keep it on the
low end so I'm gonna keep it right at
about 84 surface foot nice and safe and
a perfect speed and then when it comes
to the feed per revolution I'd say there
were about four thousandths to six
thousands in this particular case we're
just putting it right at four
thousandths to hug that bottom level
which will give us a perfect hole so one
of the things that I've done here is I
don't actually know where the end mill
is going to come down but I know that
it's gonna rough this pocket so what I
did was I actually went to this surface
and I actually drew myself a point so
that point right there and bring it up
this point right here I basically just
sketched it right there on that surface
right there and then when I call up the
drill location I'm just gonna hit that
point right there and the drill will
come down in that place and then when I
go to do the pocket with tool three I'll
tell the tool that I have a pre-drilled
hole and it will automatically know to
drop down at that exact location and
start from there another thing that I'll
point out is that this is a coolant
through drill this is a drill that is
specifically designed for hard materials
and forgetting the job done
so a lot of times when we were running
aluminum we're pecking and we're just
trying to get the material out in a
hurry in this case we're simply gonna
grab the drill wait for the coolant on
I'm gonna bring the drill down and then
we're just gonna drop full depth without
pecking and we're gonna come out and go
get the next tool nice and simple even
though it's inconel we don't have to
Peck because the coolant is actually
flooding the front end of the drill and
the drill is designed in such a way that
has it drills down it's breaking that
chip and the chips are just flowing out
of the hole
alright so now that we pre-drilled the
pocket I'm gonna go to an end mill to
rough the pocket out and rough out the
outside I'm gonna go to the Harvey three
and it is a beast of a tool my team
actually nicknamed it we called it the
zombie cutter this thing was dead and it
just kept coming alright so now let's
talk surface for when I'm in titanium
we're peripheral milling right
so the old style of machining you
actually dropped down and you're only
using the tip of the cutter the cutter
is flexing and you're taking a big cut
with the tip right but now we're
creating tool paths that instead of
plunging off a dock they actually ramp
into the material taking the pressure
off and we take a smaller radial but we
drop full depth utilizing the entire
flute length which brings stability and
rigidity and allows us to go much faster
so in titanium if you look in the
machinist handbook you'll see a hundred
seventy-five surface foot as a standard
but in ink I know it's another story
right Anka now is much harder than
titanium so the surface foot is on the
low end so instead of a hundred and
seventy five you're talking you know
fifty to a hundred surface foot right
however because of the advanced tool
paths that we're using the rigidity in
tool that we're getting the coolant that
we're using all of the variables put
together we actually run from two
hundred to four hundred surface foot in
ink you know and we do it in a
consistent manner over a long period of
time okay so that's just something that
we're practicing with so in this
specific application we're gonna run at
two hundred and ten surface foot okay
we're gonna keep it on the low end on
the inside and the outside we're gonna
drop all the way to the bottom
now our radial depth of cut so we're
full depth so if you look at the outside
you're probably at two and a half times
diameter that's deep
now radially instead of taking a big
step over we're actually to take a four
percent of diameter step over and then
we're gonna put our feed per tooth at
point zero zero four two which is going
to give us a feed rate of forty inches
per minute which is incredibly fast for
inconel and yet it's safe and will be
consistent in the cut so basically what
you see is the end mo is actually taking
about 20000 per cut but your one point
too deep right so it's just going around
and cutting all the excess material we
actually had more material on that
outsides on X than we did on Y and
that's why it's going and finishing
everything now it dropped into the
pre-drilled hole and now it's peripheral
milling and now it's actually cutting
material
[Applause]
that's gonna come over there and worry
about this section
all right so everything's been roughed
and we left five thousands on every
surface so now we're gonna come back and
we're gonna kiss it alright so a harvey
three end mill roughing inca now it's
gonna get dull no matter what it'll keep
going and sometimes go for hours but
since we're looking for a perfect
surface finish on these walls i'm simply
going to use a different tool to come
back and kiss the side so now we're
using a different are v3n mail to
actually finish the part now with tool
for we're gonna drop in to where we
previously roughed and we're just going
to kiss the bottom but guess what
instead of a twenty thousand step over
my step overs are much greater now
because i don't have all of that
material to cut through I'm only cutting
the bottom surface and I just want it to
be beautiful right so I don't want all
those lines so now instead of a twenty
thousand step over I actually have a
greater step over alright so when it
comes to the speeds and feeds on the
surface footage it's exactly the same
two hundred and ten sfm but the chip
load the feed rate per that revolution
I've dropped in half so instead of being
four thousandths where at mm chip low so
point zero zero two which gives us a
cutting feed rate of 19 inches per
minute all right so we already know what
the current rpms at forty inches a
minute it can rough all day
boom-boom-boom right but now all we've
done is taking the feed rate dropped it
in half so that we can allow those
cutters to work and give us a perfect
surface finish so tool comes down ramps
into the bottom comes over here drops
down ramps into the bottom
because the tool is pretty long and
taking the entire wall and I want to
have a perfect finish I'm actually
finishing the inside wall and then I'm
gonna do a spring pass just to catch any
of the deflection right so the tool with
the pressure is gonna want to deflect a
little bit which is gonna make it so you
might have a perfect tolerance up here
but the bottom might be a little bit
small because the tool deflected
outwards all right so now I'm coming on
the outside
I'm simply kissing the outside doing a
2d contour all the way around it and
flip around to the back just doing a 2d
contour all the way about I'm taking a
five thousandths finished pass
there's my spring pass so I'm not
cutting extra material I'm just picking
up anything that was left because the
tool deflected because I want those
walls to be perfect and perpendicular to
that top surface it took my first cut
right there
took my second cut to finish that
surface
all right so now we have come back and
actually done all our finished passes to
kiss all the surfaces on the bottom of
the pocket to make it all perfect and to
size if this was aluminum I might come
back with a sham per mil now and
actually sham for all those edges and
actually spot drill where my threads are
gonna be but this is inconel so I have a
different approach because I don't want
to send a tip of a center drill or a
chamfer mill straight into the ink you
know it might handle for a while but it
will wear out okay so strategically
knowing that the go drill is so
centering I'm actually going to drill
first and then sham / the outside
afterwards okay so this is a go drill
just like the 3/4 inch but this one has
a diameter of 0.25 7 which is the minor
ID for a 5/16 18 thread which we will
then come back and thread mill but now
we're gonna pre-drill the ID of that
thread all right so the speeds and feeds
remember what the service footage was it
was 70 to 130 in inconel so we're going
85 it comes up just under 85 but it's
basically 85 sfm alright the chip load
on the smaller is gonna change a little
bit okay so it's a little bit more
aggressive for the bigger tools on the
smaller drills I like my fee per
revolution to be about mm to 3
thousandths alright so let's just split
it in the middle and go point 0 0 to 5
and then we're just gonna drill straight
down come out go to the next hole boom
boom boom we will get a consistently
perfect series of holes
the thing there's no Peck I'm drilling
straight down the coolant is blasting
from the tip and it's just bone bone
bone all right so now that we're
finished drilling the 0.357 diameter
holes we're gonna actually bring in our
shampoo and we're gonna actually spot
those holes to create this chamfer for
the 5/16 18 thread all right
so 2 6 is gonna be a 5 8 6 flute shaffer
mill at an included angle of 90 degrees
one of my favorite products that kena
metal has is the duo lock system it's a
way to save on carbide all right so when
you have end mills they literally
instead of having this much carbide they
give you just the end mill and actually
put a tip on it that actually screws
into a body right so it connects and
then when the end mill wears out you
basically unscrew it put another insert
in screw it back lock it it locks
perfectly in place and you just keep
running and when you're running
production this saves huge money because
you don't have to pay for all that
carbide so now that we have the holes
already in place we're simply going to
drop down and sham / around the hole to
a diameter that's approximately about
10% of the overall thread diameter we're
looking at a chamfer Millie we're
talking a 90-degree included angle so
each side is 45 okay that's why it's
popular in machining especially manual
machining because it's easy to calculate
if I have a 45 degree angle all I have
to do to calculate it when actually
creating a Shaffer is go edge to edge
and basically I can just go okay I want
to sham for this edge five thousandths
all that would have to do is go a
hundred thousands off a hundred
thousands down
and then an additional five thousands
because it's a forty five-degree is
equal so 50 over 50 down a hundred over
a hundred down crates
edge to edge anything beyond that is the
sham / alright so when it comes to
inconel I'm actually have a 5/8 so an
aluminum I might say it's a hundred
thousandths and it's 50 off and 50 down
right and if I wanted to do a ten
thousand sham / I would just go sixty
down right so it's 50 off 60 down but
because it's inconel I want to use the
flute higher up and I actually want to
give it some room to actually cut
because I had six flutes okay
so on the top surface I'm basically
going to hit right kind of in the center
of the flute
alright that's good but on the bottom
surface the closer I get to the tip the
farther the tool is gonna have to be
away from this surface right so when you
look at this surface if I'm close to the
tip I'd have to pull my tool away from
that surface and that means that the
shampo would be only over here because
the tool was away from the surface so
what I'm going to do is actually call it
a larger diameter so the software takes
the tool and puts it right up against
the wall but deeper so I can get my
shampoo all the way over here so just
like a little trick right so if you run
an aluminum that's one thing if you're
running on the top that's another thing
in inconel right with a sixth flute tool
and if you're running down here in your
next tool wall we're actually going to
call it and say it's a much bigger tool
so we can actually use the top so we can
get it close to the wall leaving the
biggest chamfer possible because we want
to shatter everything inside the machine
especially when it comes to inconel all
right so speeds and feeds for our duo
lock six flute
five eighths sham four mil we're going
to go 120 surface foot and then our chip
load our feed per tooth we're putting at
point zero zero two two which puts our
revolutions at 733 and add a feed rate
of ten inches per minute alright so now
that sham per mill has actually walked
around the part inside the Part D bird
everything and it's going to sham per
the drilled holes now all right so it's
gonna come straight down so one thing
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna actually back
off my rpms because I don't want any
chatter when this thing hits when it
hits the full diameter and it starts
taking that big cut I want to keep my
rpms low so I create pressure so the
tool engages the material and it doesn't
bounce alright so we're gonna start off
with a surface footage of sixty and a
feed per revolution of mm it's gonna
drop down it's gonna be slow but it's
okay because it's inconel and it's gonna
make a perfect finish
you
all right so we're on our last and now
the last thing we're gonna do is we're
going to thread it but I'm not gonna use
a tap I'm gonna use a thread mill so
this is a great cutter it's designed
well and it actually gets the job done
quickly and perfectly alright so give
it's aluminum or steel like 303
something soft I will roll tap it or cut
tap it depending but I love thread mills
because thread mills you can compliment
right if you have a certain amount of
plating or if it's getting edged or if
they're calling out the size you know
larger because they're putting in an
answer
you can literally adjust that thread
perfectly and not just that if a thread
now drops into a hole and breaks the
thread mill is smaller than the hole
right so it usually breaks clean up at
the neck which allows you to simply stop
the machine take out the thread mill put
another one in because it's a thread
mill and the tip to the first thread is
perfect you simply can just repro bit or
re0 it and the thread mill will drop
down actually pick up the exact thread
now there's a lot of flutes on this
thread mill and that's because the
thread mill is specifically designed for
a 5/16 18 thread all right because it
has so many teeth this thread mill when
it's spinning will simply drop down move
into the major diameter of the thread in
this case a diameter of 5/16 and then it
will helical up one time for one thread
so it's 18 threads per inch so if you
divide that that would be 55,000 so it
simply goes in and as it walks around
that major diameter
at 360 degrees it raises at the same
time as it's going around so but a time
you hit 360 degrees your Z has lifted by
55 thousands and then the tool will
disengage then through the entire
diameter of the hole all of your threads
all the way up will be perfectly cut so
since this is Inca now I'm gonna walk in
I'm gonna leave five thousandths and do
one roughing pass I'm gonna come out I'm
gonna drop back down I'm gonna walk in
that extra five thousands to do my
finish I'm gonna do it one more time
and then I'm gonna come out go down I'm
gonna do it one more time just as a
spring pass not to take any material but
just to make a perfect thread and catch
any material that's left because the
tool might have deflected because it's
hanging out so long in inconel all right
so let's do this so one of the cool
things about the thread mill is you
would think that you drop down and just
like inch around it like point by bead
Raider or something very delicate and
very small but we're gonna actually get
after it a little bit okay so our
surface footage is that one hundred and
eighty all right that's a good surface
foot right there and then our feed per
tooth is at point zero zero one two
there's a three flute tool and that's
gonna put us at a cutting feed rate of
ten inches a minute ten inches a minute
doesn't seem like a lot but when you're
dropping down and you're only moving out
like 50 thousandths you get there quick
right and then when you move around in
that small little space it moves quick
so it's gonna go in boom out and boom
out the tool actually has a hole going
through the tool so coolant actually
comes out the bottom it flushes those
chips but because the diameter is 0.2 57
and the tool is 0.2 42 there's not a lot
space okay and I don't want to run those
chips over so what I'm doing with an
understanding that it's flushing the
bottom of the hole is I'm lifting up as
I'm lifting up it's flushing the bottom
is pulling all the chips out so by the
time I come up all the chips are out and
then I just drop back in walk around
again come out drop back in do my spring
pass come around for a perfect finished
thread there we go check it out the
Titan 1m extra-large inc °o° version
right there so check it out you can
actually look at all the service
finishes everything looks absolutely
perfect we put the thread gauges in the
go the no go everything is absolutely
perfect the finish is nice and smooth
all the way around part looks absolutely
beautiful we haven't done any external
finishing or deburring that is exactly
how it came out of the machine I hope
you guys learn something and if you love
this video please hit that subscribe
button below because we have a whole
bunch more just like it common CNC
machining inconel kena metal tooling
making it happen boom
you